michel fayyad analyste politique et
financier
michel fayyad bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france le courant
vient d'être rétablie rendu possible
grâce à une aide en gasoil fournis par
l'armée et pour combien de temps encore
bonjour donc l'armée effectivement est
en train de fournir l'électricité du
liban mais cette quête devrez simplement
arriver dans les quelques jours elle ne
pourrait durer que trois jours donc
c'est peut-être une solution à court
terme mais c'est pas une solution
vraiment à long terme pour le pays et il
faut dire que c'est depuis le 23
septembre que l'électricité du liban
avait prévenu le gouvernement qui n'y
aurait plus de quoi faire fournir les
centrales électriques il ya un manque de
liquidités à l'arrêt des subventions sur
les carburants et du riz et hausse des
prix c'est un cercle vicieux fatale
finalement pour le liban
oui tout à fait en fait il ya le
problème des devises étrangères puisque
effectivement la banque centrale en a
plus suffisamment pour faire ces équipes
c'est pour faire les différents achats l
arrêter les subventions sur le carburant
donc il ya aujourd'hui un de la flambée
des prix du carburant il ya une
difficulté d'approvisionnement raison de
qui tu manques de devises et vous avez
les baisses bola qui fait un peu de
communication en amenant quelques
quelques cargaison iranienne mais tout
ça c'est ça ne résout pas les problèmes
de fond en fait il ya on a fixé le prix
du kilowatt en 1994 sur la base d'un
prix au baril de 20 dollars et le baril
de pétrole est au jeu et depuis l'an
2000 le baril a systématiquement été à
plus de 20 dollars le baril aujourd'hui
on a 80 dollars le baril et donc c'est
un déficit chronique qui se passe au
niveau de l'électricité et on parle en
fait d'une que la tête en fait la dette
concernant le secteur énergétique au
liban représente 40% de l'ensemble de la
dette du pays
ce sont des pans entiers de l'économie
paralysée quelles sont les répercussions
sur la population
les répercussions sont terribles parce
que jusqu'à présent en fait lorsque
l'électricité de l'état ne fonctionnait
pas les gens vivaient grâce aux
générateurs mais les générateurs sont
fournis par des privés qui sont qui sont
organisées telles images fia c'est pour
ça que les libanais l'appelle la mafia
des générateurs mais ces gens là en fait
ça pour visionner grâce à des livraisons
grâce aux grâce au camion est en fête
avec la pénurie de carburant est bien
même les générateurs privés ne peuvent
plus fournir de l'électricité aux
libanais et vous savez très bien que
l'électricité c'est le coeur même de
l'économie de pour l'activité donc quand
un pays n'a plus de quoi de quoi voir et
de l'électricité rien ne marche plus
donc il ya un vrai problème de fond est
aujourd'hui en fait hier et des
manifestations qui ont eu lieu contre le
gouvernement parce que ce gouvernement
qui a été mise en place après treize
mois d'attentes est un gouvernement que
les libanais appelle le gouvernement des
banques donc le gouvernement des banques
par les banques pour les banques avec un
premier ministre qui est lui même
banquier l'homme le plus riche du monde
avec son frère le ministre des finances
qui est qui qui travaillait jusque-là la
banque centrale donc en fait voilà celle
aujourd'hui ça que ce sur quoi les
libanais insiste il faudrait donc encore
une fois à nouveau gouvernement pour
réformer entièrement le secteur de
l'énergie y'a pas ça il ya également des
négociations qui sont en cours avec
l'egypte et la jordanie l'aide de l'irak
ces deux solutions qui sont à court
terme tout ça mais dans le futur c'est
la problématique principale pour la
population
oui est tout à fait en fait il ya eu des
plots qui ont été mises en place cinq
qui ont été imaginés auparavant donc il
ya eu un plan comptable or en deux et le
quatre 2005
on appelait cela le plan serena wii qui
était ce qui a été fait que le ministre
sortant de l'économie monnaie
et il ya eu un second plan en 2010
présenté par le ministre
je compte ils étaient approuvés
petit problème la réforme on les
connaissait dire qu'il faut passer un
petit problème technique michel fayyad
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
tout cas je rappelle que vous êtes
analyses politiques et financiers